My co-author of the book Altered Traits is
a neuroscientist, Richard Davidson.
He has a lab at the University of Wisconsin.
It’s a very large lab, he has dedicated
scanners, he has about 100 people working
there, and he was able to do some remarkable
research where he flew Olympic level meditators—who
live in Nepal or India typically, some in
France—he flew them over to the lab and
put them through a protocol in his brain scanners
and did state-of-the-art tests and the results
were just astounding.
We found, for example, or he found that their
brain waves are really different.
Perhaps the most remarkable findings in the
Olympic level meditators has to do with what’s
called a gamma wave.
All of us get gamma for a very short period
when we solve a problem we’ve been grappling
with, even if it’s something that’s vexed
us for months.
We get about half second of gamma; it’s
the strongest wave in the EEG spectrum.
We get it when we bite into an apple or imagine
biting into an apple, and for a brief period,
a split-second, inputs from taste, sound,
smell, vision, all of that come together in
that imagined bite into the apple.
But that lasts very short period in an ordinary
EEG.
What was stunning was that the Olympic level
meditators, these are people who have done
up to 62,000 lifetime hours of meditation,
their brainwave shows gamma very strong all
the time as a lasting trait just no matter
what they’re doing.
It’s not a state effect, it’s not during
their meditation alone, but it’s just their
every day state of mind.
We actually have no idea what that means experientially.
Science has never seen it before.
We also find that in these Olympic level meditators
when we asked them, for example, to do a meditation
on compassion their level of gamma jumps 700
to 800 percent in a few seconds.
This has also never been seen by science.
So we have to assume that the special state
of consciousness that you see in the highest
level meditators is a lot like something described
in the classical meditation literatures centuries
ago, which is that there is a state of being
which is not like our ordinary state.
Sometimes it’s called liberation, enlightenment,
awake, whatever the word may be we suspect
there’s really no vocabulary that captures
what that might be.
The people that we’ve talked to in this
Olympic level group say it’s very spacious
and you’re wide open, you’re prepared
for whatever may come, we just don’t know.
But we do know it’s quite remarkable.